Speaker 1: Let's go next to RJ from Wisconsin.
RJ, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi there, Jan again.
Hey, thank you for taking my call.
I want to say I personally am fairly relieved
about the result of yesterday's trial.
It seems that upwards of maybe eighty five
to eighty eight percent of America is as well.
But I guess I want to touch on something that's
been coming up in the news, and that's the
shooting that occurred in Columbus as well,
and all of the protests that are coming as
a result of that.
Right.
Watch that video.
Several times, and obviously nobody knows
the exact details of that yet, but I guess
my question to you is, do we?
Need to in some ways draw a line to where
we're willing to protest some of these things
if the use of force is.
Is is use of force ever a justifiable method
from law enforcement and is there a line that
we are going to draw as Democrats or as as
liberals that.
We would be willing to accept any reason for
use of force by a police officer
Speaker 1: or so are you are you saying are
there any circumstances where it's OK for
police to use deadly force?
Is that your question?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess in what circumstance
would that be OK?
I mean, it looked to me from the video and
again, I'm just going off of what I've seen
in slow motion.
I was but it like the one individual had had
possibly a knife or something like that that
was going after another individual.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I haven't I haven't
seen this specific video, but certainly there
are of course, there are situations where
police use of force up to deadly force is
is warranted.
What we want is for as a society to have a
really good feeling that police are good at
determining when that's appropriate.
And you can go through all sorts of different
scenarios.
And active gunman and police show up certain
hostage situations, someone who's about to
set off a bomb.
I mean, I recognize and accept the legal framework
in which police are able to use up to deadly
force.
But I think the debate I've not heard any
I mean, OK, I guess there's some people who
don't want police at all.
And maybe they would say police shouldn't
ever even fire a gun no matter what.
It's more
Speaker 2: far left.
Speaker 1: Ninety nine percent of every 100
percent of everyone I've personally spoken
to understands that sometimes police use deadly
force and it is appropriate.
Speaker 3: Right, and I guess I guess my question
is, is, is if there are clear instances where
obviously police intervention and use of deadly
force is necessary.
Yes.
But, you know, given that, you know.
I guess in terms of going forward with protests
and things like that, if we're, you know,
are we willing to on our side acknowledge
the fact that maybe there is, you know, say
in that situation, if they had, you know,
if the individual did have a knife and was
going after after the other individual, you
know, are we willing to accept that?
Yes, because that was an African-American.
That was that was unfortunately shot by a
white police officer that we're willing to
admit that that was that was a justifiable
use of force in that instance.
Speaker 1: Listen, you'd have to ask people
who I guess are on some other side of this.
My my view is that just the race of that of
an officer and the race of the person that
gets shot doesn't tell you whether the actions
of the officer were acceptable.
That's my position.
You're getting into a lot of other other things
that don't really reflect my views.
So I would maybe talk to people who are more
of that of that mindset.
I appreciate the phone call very much.
And it's an important question, but I think
that it's also important not to.
I mean, police should never use force.
Period is not one I've really heard.
So I'm not inclined to spend too much time
arguing about it because it seems ninety nine
point nine percent of the country is on the
same page on that.
OK, I'm up.
I apologize.
I wasn't able to pick up a more phone calls.
I did what I could.
We will take a break and we will take calls
again.